Get down.
I think people hear "robot"
and they think Terminator or RoboCop.
Your move, creep.
The idea that you could
build a new organism
that has never existed from cells
that does something
we've never seen before,
essentially a biological machine,
has really captured the imagination.
If xenobots sound like science
fiction brought to life,
it's because they are.
They're biological machines
made by humans but designed by computers.
This project offers a new way
to make what you might call a robot
that's very different from
existing robotic technologies.
A machine for a new purpose,
not to recapitulate biology
or build a heart, but to build
something that could do work
for any number of tasks
that you'd use a traditional robot for.
So it's kind of a weird marriage
between robotics and
computer science and biology.
These tiny specks seen here
under a microscope are xenobots,
made of about 5,000 living skin cells.
They get their name
from the African clawed
frog Xenopus Laevis,
which supplies their cells.
They can't reproduce
and they will only live
for around 10 days, feeding
on the small platelets
of yolk that fill each of their cells.
Really, this was the
first time we thought,
could you take stem cells
and build something from the ground up?
And the idea is really
to take these stem cells
very early in development, collect them
and essentially have
different types of cells,
like you would different Lego blocks.
Cells already act like little machines,
some contract and expand,
others capture material.
By shaping these cells,
you create the machine.
So you could imagine a red
Lego block is a heart cell
and a green Lego block is a skin cell.
And then really similar to building Legos
where you just sort of
start connecting the pieces
from the bottom up, we build
our robots in the same way.
We just build cell by cell
until we get to a final shape and form.
Xenobots are designed
and then evolve using
artificial intelligence
before they're made.
Sam Kriegman is a graduate student
at the University of Vermont
and designed that computer program.
Unlike every other organism
that has ever existed
before on this planet,
the xenobots evolve inside
of computer simulations
and the computer simulates
the physical world,
but it can do so very rapidly
and many worlds at once
and so, it can do evolution
in days instead of millennia
and at the end of this
evolutionary process,
it prints out a blueprint that tells us
how to build a new organism
for some desired task
from essentially scratch from
existing biological materials.
The simulated xenobots are subjected
to physics engines similar
to those in video games.
The AI assesses how variants
will perform and makes changes
according to the tasks they're set.
This is natural selection
put on fast-forward
with a computer at the controls.
Evolution on Earth works as
a long chain of mutations,
tiny revisions to existing
designs, one after the other
over millions or billions of years.
And sometimes, we can speed this up
by selectively breeding
crops and livestock and dogs
so that their offspring have
desired characteristics.
But it's very unlikely
that you could select from wolves or dogs
anything that you wouldn't call a dog.
But with computers, we
can speed up this process.
So we can simulate a
billion years of evolution
in a day or in a week on a super computer.
The computer selects its
top candidates to build
and only then do humans
come back into the picture.
The AI generated blueprints
are sent off to Dr. Blackiston
and his wet lab at Tufts
University, Massachusetts.
Right, so this
is the fun part, it's a bit like sculpting
and some designs are not possible
to be built biologically currently.
They have features that
are too difficult to shape
or construct like right
angles, very small gaps.
But we often get five
or six excellent designs
that are completely buildable in the lab,
which is where we port
everything over into the wet lab
and build them by hand manually.
We then build from the ground up
using those different cells
the shape that new one,
and it typically starts as a sphere.
So the cells round off
and make a roughly round
shape after 24 hours
and then we go in with a
pair of surgical forceps
that we polish with the
sharpening stone manually
and also a very small cautery electorate.
We carve away from that sphere the design
and sculpt the final shape
that we would like to
match the computer design
and that's really sort of the amazing part
in the innovation is this,
this sculpting aspect
to give you a very, very
precise three-dimensional shape
at only the scale of about
half of a millimeter.
Right now, xenobots are made
of only about 5,000 skin
and heart muscle cells, but
they can perform basic tasks
like moving in a straight line,
carrying objects from one spot to another
and behaving collectively.
Xenobots don't need to
be that sophisticated
to supply some kind of social utility.
We found that even the xenobots
that simply swirl around in their dish,
they tended to clean their
dish as they moved through it.
So that is, they tended
spontaneously to sweep up
and corral any detritus in their dish
into centralized, neat little piles.
Why they do that is still
somewhat of a mystery.
We evolve them in the computer
simulation simply to move
and we got something for free
because they're living systems
that have their own agenda
and do useful things
that weren't necessarily
programmed, like cleaning.
At the moment, all xenobots
are constructed out of frog cells,
but if human cells were used instead,
then there's huge medical
potential for these machines.
Potentially, they could simply by swirling
around in an artery, scrape
plaque off of the walls
or abrade calcium deposits
in arthritic joints.
With a little bit more bio-engineering,
we can imagine targeted drug delivery,
which is something that
we've been thinking about
even in our very simple simulations.
So, when we evolve inside
of a computer a xenobot
to carry a little pellet
from one position to
another target position,
what that's getting at
is, could these be used
to transport something useful,
not just a pellet, but a drug
or medicine to the precise
location of disease?
And so, the advantage of using
a human patient's own cells
is that the immune response
system wouldn't flush it out,
unlike other micro
robotic delivery systems
made of metal, for example.
If the production
of xenobots, which exists right now,
could be scaled up hugely,
by automating them with 3D printers,
then they could be used to tackle issues
on a global scale, such as pollution.
We could imagine without too
much further bioengineering
simply swarms of xenobots
that swirl around and clean,
could be used in the environment
to clean up little
microscopic bits of plastic,
to aggregate them into
a larger ball of plastic
that could be identified
and picked up by traditional
robots, boats, or drones,
and then taken to a recycling center.
Just wear and tear on
robots is awful difficult.
So, it's very easy to lose
functionality with small changes,
especially when you're
dealing with physical motors.
It's fairly catastrophic when
there's any sort of damage.
But biological systems
for millions of years
have been optimized to resist
wear and tear and damage
and certainly, amphibians
have many of the same pathways
that we humans do.
So, leveraging that's been great,
it gives us the ability to have organisms
that when they're damaged,
can continue functioning
even with fairly catastrophic damage.
So you can largely bisect the xenobot
and it will zipper itself
back up in about five minutes
and continue on doing what it did before
and this is really amazing.
We haven't seen another
system that can do something
to that extreme.
And Blackiston and
Kriegman believe it's not
just the xenobots that are revolutionary,
but also the supercomputer
that's used to create them.
One day, it could potentially
help humans redesign themselves.
We have supercomputers
that can run millions
of simulations per minute
and it also can be optimized
for whatever we would like.
So as humans, we often have goals
that may be slightly different
than natural selection.
And we can now have the
computer set up evolution
and sort of get through
this bottleneck much faster.
So for example, for the heart,
we're seeing that with the types of diets
that humans eat now,
there may be some other
type of heart valve
or even some process in the body
or vasculature that's superior
to what we humans have
and the computer can likely hone in
on those types of changes very quickly.
I think that the point of
the computer simulations
isn't just to speed up evolution.
It's that human designers
have really strong biases
in the kinds of artifacts that we make.
So, when a human goes to design a robot,
they inevitably will copy
some familiar object.
The robot will look like a
dog or a human or a plant
that they've seen before,
some kinds of shapes that
are familiar to them.
Now, the computer
doesn't share our biases.
It might have it's own biases in it.
But it will come up with
designs that look nothing
like any organism or thing
that we've seen in the world
And then it's a matter of
tackling all the big ethical
and societal questions about
should those be implemented?
How much control should we have
over our bodies and the design
of humans or other organisms?
These are the same things
that the plant scientists
have been grappling with, right?
It's can you make a bigger tomato?
Can you make a bigger apple? Should you?
Should you make it pesticide resistant?
And I think what we're going
see are those questions
moving into humans very soon.
We're starting small,
we're using xenobots,
but you can extrapolate this on up.
So, if a computer is so good
at designing a microorganism,
could the computer design a better horse?
Could the computer design a better cat?
Could this computer make
something that's more efficient,
a better heart for humans,
if given the right amount of information
and the right amount
of synthetic evolution?
And so, I think there's a real push
to understand how can AI be
harnessed to really capitalize
and even push where evolution
has gotten us to this point.